[Music]
[Laughter]
hey folks we are live you have just seen
a scrambling to get things going so here
we are welcome to the Dark Horse podcast
is this our 29:29 yet live stream in a
few short months in a few short months
yes so we've got lots to do and talk
about today we are also being filmed as
we speak by CBS which wants to talk
about canceled culture I don't know if
they have advanced warning that we are
soon to be canceled again but it is
possible that another cancellation is
coming so keep your eye out for that I
have also asked them if we could
possibly talk on CBS about unity 2020
and that possibility exists so please
keep your eye out for further
information that may come across your
regular old TV through the network
in the meantime should we also say that
did you already say that zach is a
couple hundred miles away today yes Zach
has run off he put a yeah he's a sheet
and he filled it with some clothes and I
don't know what else a laptop and he
threw it over a stick on her shoulder
and he wandered out there I've gotten a
couple hundred miles away he is remotely
monitoring this but he is in no position
to save us if things go wrong so let's
hope they do not all right all right dr.
Hine
dr. Weinstein I have promised my twitter
followers that I will talk about unity
2020 at the top here so they don't have
to wait if that's what they're waiting
for
oh I see I've got things sticking up and
back well there's nothing to be done at
this point is there ah okay unity 2020
here's the here's the deal it is going
great at one level we are discovering
the most amazing set of Patriots these
are people who are frightened about
where we're headed people who love their
country and are ready to sacrifice for
it and they are showing up to offer all
kinds of help skills that we definitely
need
so things are rapidly in motion as I
have mentioned before there is a curious
lack the people who tell us that they
are very much on board with the plan do
not always do anything that allows us to
count them so that we can say how many
people are actually rooting for us and I
wanted to talk a little bit about why I
think that might be so before you talk
about why you think there's a failure
somewhere why don't you say both here
don't you bracket this conversation by
saying what what should be happening
what would you like people to be doing
well here's the long and short of it the
long and short of it is there is exactly
one thing that we do not have and this
plan could actually work believe it or
not it is not too late everything that
needs to happen can happen what we need
is a visible groundswell of American
citizens eligible to vote what where do
they sign up go to the place that you
want them to be signing up we want them
to go to the website articles of unity
org you will find there are links to
offer your volunteer support to sign up
for our email list and let us know where
you are and what you're thinking so
please do that you should also follow
our Twitter account if you are on
Twitter articles of unity at articles of
unity those are the places to go there
will be more opportunities showing up
this week and so anyway those are the
places to sign up for you to find out
about what is emerging and yes we are
looking for your help but really you
want to do something for us find two
people with ears to hear and tell them
that's it
two people and then you ask them can you
find two people that'll work right that
way you won't know that will have
happened unless they also sign unless
they show up at those at those addresses
yeah all right so now I want to talk to
you I'm noticing I need to Center myself
a little bit more on the shot okay
here's the model that I came up with as
I was driving back from dropping Zach at
his bicycle maintenance course that he
is taking what I realized was that we
are hearing pushback from a couple of
quadrants and one of those quadrants are
people who say things to us like this
like a great plan how about waiting till
2024 when we've already allowed Joe
Biden to clear Donald Trump from the
White House etcetra etcetra could you
please just shelve this plan seems
really cool but like I said that sounds
like a great idea because it will give
all of the enemies of the plan much more
time to organize and get their [ __ ]
together I hadn't even thought of that
that's a great point here's the thing if
you are somebody who has been alarmed
about the corruption of our system and
the role that the duopoly plays in that
corruption if you've been aware of that
for decades then you know that every
single election cycle we go through this
right you say you know what this is not
gonna solve itself the duopoly has a
lock on power and that lock on power is
being used to serve interests that are
not the interests of the American people
what are we going to do about it if you
say oh through the normal channels go
ahead and go through the normal channels
but if you say well we've done that and
it doesn't work and you say maybe we
have to do something else what happens
next is people say ah if you do
something else you will elect the
greater evil and this will be your fault
right and nobody wants to be your fault
Yeah right
we've seen that happen to people like
Ralph Nader 2020 is being set up to
explain the reelection of Trump right
when in fact we can squarely point at
the DNC well first of all the DNC is
responsible for this in more ways than
one
the RNC as well the duopoly has er
played tag team with their little
corruption racket and so in any case you
will hear each election cycle you will
hear you're going to elect the greater
evil and this is going to be your fault
and then if you persist you will be told
well you can't do it this time because
of the Supreme Court right this is just
every single every single election cycle
it's amazing the Supreme Court always
seems to be on the verge of retirement
and collapse it's funny it's almost as
if it's staffed by mortals who have a
lifespan and ultimately end up retiring
and need to be replaced so it's never
the time for something not to suggest
that the makeup of the Supreme Court
isn't critical but it's it's always sort
of I don't know what was that the second
or the third rejoinder - it has to be
now well let's put it this way the fact
that it is critical this time is not an
argument against something different
because it only gets more critical over
time so if you think it's critical now
and that's a reason not to do it
you
actually got it backwards now is the
time we have to do it because next time
it's gonna be even more critical
so people are suggesting going back in
time if they have a mechanism I'm all
ears
but in any case here's the thing I have
heard so many times that you can't do it
because you'll elect a greater evil
the whole structure of this plan is
built to address that concern right we
don't have that problem because we have
structurally built a mechanism that will
not spoil the election so in spite of
that fact we are getting this pushback
from certain people who say lovely plan
all ears
do it in 2024 and we'll get we'll get on
board but not now because of the problem
so I want to tell you about my model
that I came up with as I was driving
back the model is this for many people
Donald Trump is the equivalent of a rock
in your shoe right if you've ever had a
rock in your shoe and you've all had
rocks in our shoe right a rock in your
shoe is top priority it's very hard to
ignore right every step it reminds you
that this has to be dealt with and there
are a lot of people who are experiencing
Trump is the rock in their shoe that
needs to be dealt with but we've got a
rock in our shoe at the same time that
we've got basically the equivalent of a
famine right we have a duopoly that has
concentrated its power and built a
system that you can never escape and it
has essentially denied people access to
the policy mechanisms that are supposed
to serve their needs and this has gone
on for decades and because of that
people are not only frozen out of the
well-being that they produce through
their labor but they are also aware of
it and they're sick of it they know that
the system is rigged they may not know
exactly in what way it is rigged but
they're angry and here's the important
point whether or not the rock in the
shoe is the one thing you can think of
or it's one on a set of high priorities
that all have to be addressed has to do
in some sense with how threatened by the
famine you are if you're especially well
positioned in society then from your
perspective it may well make sense we
have to deal with
rocking our shoe because even in a
famine you wouldn't want to leave a rock
in your shoe because you whatever you're
gonna do to deal with the famine getting
the rock out of your shoe first makes
sense so if you're not directly
threatened by the famine then you will
think Rock and your shoe is the only
thing we got and you'll say stuff like
well why don't you wait till 2024
right let's deal with the rock and our
shoe and then 2024 we can deal with the
famine but for anybody who's either
starving or threatened with starvation
that doesn't make any sense because the
rock and the shoe is a high priority and
the famine is a high priority and we're
gonna have to do something to deal with
both of them maybe we got to get the
rock out but we've also got to deal with
the famine and here's an election in
which you could do both could I read to
you a couple of sentences from an
excellent document that I found from
almost ten years ago please do recent
decades this is from 2011 recent decades
have witnessed a de facto coup against
the democratic structures of the world
and the wholesale capture and sabotage
of the entire public regulatory
apparatus the co-opted structures have
been redirected and now served to
liquidate the world's resources and
concentrate wealth and power in the
hands of a tiny unelected elite only the
costs remain public and it goes on this
is from the declaration of
interdependence which you wrote during
occupy and which proceeds to make a
number of highly specific and actionable
bullet points about what to do just to
the argument that not now not now please
wait until next time when there's a
greater chance of success when there
will presumably be no two evils to
choose between this was the first time
that I know that you had formalized in
writing some of exactly the concerns
that you have laid out in the first
whatever five minutes of this livestream
today this is from 2011 that's amazing
thank you you know I have thought
frequently during this unity 2020 phase
I've thought about that document and I
just literally have not had the time to
go find it but yeah I wrote the
declaration of interdependence and it's
it lays out exactly the problem and what
that tells you is that the fact that
that bit that you read there is equally
applicable today that tells you some of
us have been aware of this for quite
some time and we've tried to call
people's attention to it and what people
have been is to calm to address it yeah
and yeah let me say that you know we we
as as we have
making clear throughout you know had
been anyway still are lifelong Democrats
liberals progressives you know much to
the irritation of some in our audience
but this was written in 2011 this was
written during Obama's first term we we
were so hopeful about Obama in the
beginning and that does not mean that we
did not critique during his his first
and certainly his second term what it
was that was actually being accomplished
after that great rhetorical movement
that actually got him elected and it was
it's what it was it was rhetoric it was
a rhetoric it was a rhetorical with me
you're absolutely right about that and
you know I still like a lot of the
rhetoric but the fact is he's great
didn't translate into policy that serve
people and what that tells you is that
the duopoly I mean let's face facts folk
they they don't want to solve the
problem not because they wouldn't
ideally like to do it also but it is
counterproductive from the point of view
of the thing that they actually do which
is deliver well-being to a small number
of very powerful entities that have
bought access right it's it's an
influence peddling racket so we
shouldn't expect them we should expect
them to deliver us rhetoric and
symbolism and false solutions until we
finally get wise to it and my point
would be well maybe it's time we finally
got wives to it I mean collectively
enough that we can actually evict them
from the positions from which they
capture all of the well-being that
should be widely available and deliver
it to their own yeah it's really uh it's
quite a thing but if you are hearing the
same thing we are hearing if you are
hearing people say well that's a cool
plan how about we try that in 2024 think
about whether or not the people who are
telling you that are really telling you
that from their perspective the famine
isn't such a big deal because on the
whole the duopoly has probably
inadvertently in most of their cases
serve their interest just by virtue of
where in society they are and for people
who are closer to the bottom of the
ladder or who have fallen off the bottom
of the ladder this has been critical for
decades right the danger to to working
people is so extreme that now we see
quite predictable movements in the
street of people
but frankly shouting incoherently to
tear the thing down because all they can
see is the harm that it does because
that harm is concentrated where they are
so that is all very important now I
would point to the last thing here which
is really the place that's harder that I
find hardest to make the point it has
long been true that the Democratic Party
in particular has delivered symbolism in
lieu of actual well-being right that's
been their go-to strategy this party did
you say is particularly prone to that
well it's not that one party is
particularly prone to it it's that the
Democratic Party has traditionally
served the interests of working people
and so having shifted away from that now
it has to deliver symbolism in lieu of
actual policy you know back as symbols
are cheaper they are cheaper but in this
case the symbols have begun to run out
people aren't buying it anymore right we
went through eight years of Obama and
things did not get better so we know
that the rhetoric doesn't add up to
policy that actually serves people we
know that we still have you know a
system of medical care for example that
people can't access and that is
dependent on their relationship with
their employer and that the economic
system is fragile in the way it's
constructed and so you can lose your
health care you know at the drop of a
hat so what has changed is the
Democratic Party seems to be toying with
a mechanism to deliver many people who
are stressed out by what I'm calling the
famine to deliver them something well
the something that they're going to
deliver is well-being that currently is
held by other people who are in a
similar strata in other words the
intersectional thing is about pointing
people who are angry about having been
frozen out redirecting them away from
the places where well-being is actually
concentrated and pointing them at
another group of citizens and this is
the most deeply unpatriotic move you can
imagine pointing Americans at each other
rather than dealing with the fact that
opportunity has concentrated at the top
is just a pall to use the pie analogy
the zero-sum nonzero-sum language that
we have used it is possible that growth
some growth in some sectors can contain
you but even if we assume that we are in
zero-sum space at a national level with
regard to well-being and I'm not saying
that that's true but even if we assume
that what you are saying if I if I hear
you correctly is there is some some pie
for you no and this is going to be hard
to operationalize but you know for well
being which is you know to some degree
that good proxies resources there for
all of Americans and what you were
pointing out is that the elite the 1%
the people with power have observed that
a number of people are seeing this you
know since occupy since before then
right and saying well if we can pit some
of the kind of haves
against the recognizing have-nots
against each other we can redefine what
the pie actually is to be that very tiny
sliver of the actual pie while we keep
all the rest of it so it's like a pie
within a pie and the people with most of
it are successfully redefining what the
actual pie is and causing the rest of us
to fight amongst ourselves yeah so I was
toying with the idea that Biden was to
let them eat cake candidate that that's
really the nature of Joe Biden at the
moment and you fixed that analogy
beautifully remember what you said not
at the moment you said no he's to let
them eat their cake candidate oh yeah
because in this seat and let them eat
cake there's no cake that's the point
the rent-seeking elites in the monarchy
don't understand that there's no cake
right and so that's an absurdly they
have cake only they have cake so they
think cake is everywhere in this case
there is cake well there's an abundance
of there's such an abundance of cheap
goods that were exactly the things that
were limiting until like a second ago
historically speaking that yeah
let them eat their cake cakes available
right and so in this case instead of
taking the you know and again we have to
draw a distinction between the
productivity of elites which actually
serves everybody and the rent-seeking of
people who become powerful some of them
have gotten powerful through being
highly productive and contributing
things that matter but once they are
productive it's very hard to resist they
don't even necessarily know that they
are engaged in Reds rent-seeking
there are just opportunities that
and they do that which pays and many of
those opportunities are
rent-seeking by definition so the DNC
has decided to point us at each other
and the basic point is well there's not
enough cake but if this group goes after
the cake of that group then the
rent-seeking elites can continue on for
another four eight who knows how many
election cycles or eight years the goods
analogy gets twisted but it's like a
cupcake within a pie
well there are twisted baked goods not
that many but some very you know like a
delicious ones yeah yeah all right so
anyway that's the developing model yeah
and here's the question
presumably if you're watching or
listening to this podcast you're you're
wise to this stuff you're aware of game
theory you're aware of what rent-seeking
is and why it's a hazard you're aware of
the evolutionary forces that will take a
corrupt system and make it more corrupt
because the loopholes will tend to self
enlarge so if you can see it then isn't
this the moment wouldn't you like in
four months for us to have turned the
corner for something unexpected new and
potentially very desirable to have
happened wouldn't you like adults at the
helm I mean don't you have a right to
demand that as an American have adults
at the helm don't we all
so how about it fabulous all right so I
know you have things on on your agenda
for today yeah you know nothing as big
but it all plays into part of why we
need that we need big structural change
right so maybe this is this is all kind
of working by fire here or I'm gonna
have us put something up on the screen
if we can you didn't just suggest a
trial by fire did you I was about to and
there hi hi I stopped let's see if you
have we can get em on our yeah you're
hot because sack is many hundreds of
miles away say that Hey look at that
look at that it's like magic okay for
those of you listening in podcast space
sorry you're gonna get a lot of this
this time okay so here's a guy
Christopher Ruffo I don't I don't know
how but he's written I really
quite extraordinary thread Twitter on
Twitter the first tweet of which reads
the City of Seattle held a training
session for white employees called quote
interrupting internalized racial
superiority and whiteness end quote
so why did a public records request he
says to find it exactly what this means
let's go through it together in this
thread so it's it's worth looking at
it's all the same garbage I want us to
go through this little this first flyer
that he talks about and then I also want
to talk about since I went to the
excruciating exercise last week of
reading white fertility of just giving a
little bit of ammunition to people who
are being forced to read it as if it is
an actually anti-racist argument when in
fact it's it's quite not so first this
again the City of Seattle which you know
the whole Pacific Northwest
unfortunately which we live in and love
it but this is a bit of a hotbed of this
kind of thinking suggests that
internalized racial superiority reveals
itself in values such as individualism
intellectualization comfort and
objectivity and there are a number of
other things on this list but this is
this is the sort of thing we've seen
over and over again it is basically
equating Enlightenment values and
science with the idea and and
understanding all human beings as
individuals with the idea of racial
superiority as if those aren't exactly
ideas that we should want everyone to
have an embrace and engage in and on the
internalized racial inferiority list we
have addiction as if that is particular
to people who have suffered under racism
rage self hate self-doubt shame
let's see hopelessness apathy
invisibility again this this movement is
about division this movement is about
separating us and unfortunately what it
feels like so we were just talking in
terms of music at the DNC the power
elite for
half-ish of the country looking at the
accumulation of resources by a few and
seeking trying to put off in the attempt
to access those resources by the many
and they are looking to divide us but
here's part of how that works that they
are embracing this incredibly divisive
movement that goes by many different
names intersectional ISM woke politics
social justice politics identity
politics and it serves to divide there
any things on this list that you want to
address well I want to I want to point
out that the tragedy of taking the
values that are the stuff power is made
of and not democratizing them basically
declaring them null and void is it's
it's utterly tragic and it's obviously
not going to work because anybody who
holds on to those tools is going to have
an advantage over anybody who decides
those tools are not the stuff of power
so the only right solution has ever been
to democratize these things and
distribute them as widely as possible
yeah so in some sense I think if you
concede that far if you can just simply
recognize hey there's stuff that makes
people powerful like for example science
right you got two choices we can also
declare science we can declare it unfair
or null and void or whatever we can
hashtag shutdown stem right what world
does that lead to if we decide that
science is no longer valid it leads to a
world in which whoever didn't listen to
us has the advantage or we can
democratize science and we know how to
do it right you and I were doing that
for 15 years it's not it's very
enjoyable rewarding work to democratize
science so the same goes almost everyone
who showed up in our classrooms was
capable of learning and grappling with
the tools of scientific inquiry of
observing patterns and posing hypotheses
and trying to distinguish between those
hypotheses and you know some of our
students came from elite academic
backgrounds but most of them did not
that wasn't the kind of school it was
and so you know we had people who had
you know if he would fill that a high
school who would you know who had who
had never gotten degrees and who showed
up and you know many of them were
brilliant and some of them were just you
know average and the school system
failed them because that's what it does
and almost to a person they were able to
do exactly what we're talking about to
engage in an attempt at objectivity as
they looked to understand the world
because once you understand what is
going on then then you can seek to
change it if you pretend that the world
is not what it is that it is much harder
to change it from some fiction to
presumably some new fiction like for
instance a utopia and even the students
I don't think they ended up in our
classes very frequently but even the
student who at the point they get to
college aren't really capable of that a
they could be capable of it if somebody
was willing to invest enough time and be
absolutely everybody who is born with a
healthy brain and I don't mean mine I
mean a healthy brain yeah can develop
into somebody who can wield these tools
if they're given a developmental
environment that reinforces that so to
the extent that there's any concern the
capacity is built-in to us right these
were tools developed by humans who
frankly knew a hell of a lot less than
we do that's right and the tools just
simply work by virtue of the fact
they're elegant and once you get the
hang of it you know you don't even think
about thinking scientifically it just
happens to you so so do you want to take
that down now so I can look at my notes
yeah try to remember how that works I'll
start talking while you're figuring that
out so this this thing that we were just
showing you guys is really it's straight
out of this crazy round Angelou book
white fragility it precedes that by a
lot actually I have a I found an essay
that I wrote from 1991 in which I'm
pointing out the pitting of modernity
versus postmodernity which I'll actually
share a couple of pics from well later
so you know to those who say you guys
helped create this beast no no we didn't
we're not wording not copping to that
just no but you know James Lindsey Peter
Burke
Hellen pluck rose as the people who put
together that grievance studies expose I
guess they don't want to call it a hoax
this precedes D'Angelo but it's the
current Bible of the moment so in the
last episode I attempted to steal man
may be her most irritating point right
the idea that all white people are
racist and I said well if you if you
understand that she's redefining what
racist means and now a racist means in
her world is that you are accruing
benefits from an historical system of
racism inequality then it's true yes if
you have white skin you continue to
accrue the benefits from an historical
system of racism and quality that is
true but redefining the keyword and the
sentiment is cheating here are some
other things that happen in the book
that you know I hope I hope you don't
have to read it but if you do
she conflate systemic problems and this
is to that to that redefinition of the
word racism she conflate systemic
problems with individual ones while
claiming to be very clear on the
differences so it's kind of a it's a
bait and switch with regard to the
system is rigged and therefore you're a
racist well no you can't you can't do
that individuals and populations are
different
she also conflates a biological
understanding of humanity which is part
of what we are trying to share with the
world with social Darwinism so social
Darwinism as a phrase in which both are
capitalized is a long debunked
bastardization of Darwinism
which has nothing really to do with an
actual evolutionary understanding of the
world
but this bastardization known as social
Darwinism suggests that current social
conditions are inevitable and good you
know it's an excuse for why the richer
rich the richer rich because Darwin said
so because nature said so no that's
wrong and that's not how evolution works
but she she makes this kind of kind of
point and thus slotting scientists like
us into this twisted in archaic belief
system
she sort of just leaves that for for her
adherence to come back to she posits
among other things that if we are indeed
all equal which many of us believe us to
be the only explanation for disparities
and condition must be the result of
discrimination
and here she's conflating equal with
identical to right equal and identical
to are not the same thing
she rails against the way that Black
History Month is celebrated because she
says it's it reinforces whiteness this
will not be the first time if you're
reading this book that you face a
dilemma
you can't win you're damned if you do
damned if you don't should we then not
celebrate Black History Month
well then violence is silence is
violence but if you do celebrate it in
any way at all apparently then you're
doing it wrong and you're further
demonstrating your your racism silence
is violence and saying the wrong thing
is violence or its equivalent therefore
your choice is to repeat after us and
the problem is there's then no basis
whatsoever to object on the because
what's being said is incorrect which
almost all of it is or because the
policy proposals that are being advanced
are going to lead to the destruction of
things on which we are all depending
there are lots that mean and this of
course happened to us in microcosm at
Evergreen yep because the primary among
the many objections I would say the
primary objection to what was being
advocated was that it would destroy the
college and that lots of people
including us including our students
including the very people that they were
claiming to be helping we're depending
on the college being functional and you
know driving it into bankruptcy wasn't
going to help anybody so it's right yeah
was there was there language at
Evergreen to say that you were actually
about to [ __ ] the college and that
nothing that you're talking about could
possibly be accomplished if you do that
nope because the very fact of objecting
meant that they were going to portray it
was racist yes because because the
movement has declared has named itself
cleverly and this is not the first time
we've seen this there are many examples
of movements like this an tyfa is one
frankly pro-life is one but anti-racist
no actually not you know I I'm here to
say I'm anti anti-racist and that does
not make me racist no because the
movement is named in a way that is that
is designed to trap you and if so to go
back to the to the
specifically for just a couple of
moments if you don't view race as the
single most defining feature of the
human experience the single most
defining feature of the human experience
you are according to the book white
fragility both racist and in denial used
to be of course that viewing everything
through racial lens was what made you a
racist well times change don't they so
this book is a hot mess of sloppy
scholarship and cherry-picked data but
that's not actually its biggest flaw let
me just quote DeAngelo herself here a
couple times from the book she says she
says I have been unable to hide my
surprise that the black man is the
school principal of all white people she
writes I realized that we see ourselves
as entitled to and deserving of more
than people of color deserve Wow she's
right about one thing she's racist like
Robert D'Angelo is actually racist and
it seems that it's possible that it's
her personal racism that has projected
all the rest of white America at the
moment that's given jet fuel to riots
that started as protests that were good
faith and had a germ of necessity at the
at the core of them that we now have a
totally chaotic and undefensible
movement so if you don't share Rob and
Angela racism as in fact the vast
majority of Americans don't your
defensive nests at being misunderstood
and caricatured as many of you who have
had to sit through sit through some of
these workplace trainings will have
experienced that's going to be held up
itself as proof of your racism and your
desire to defend yourself against false
claims being evidence of your white
fragility your white supremacism is in
fact it's another rhetorical trick and
it's I think the central Kafka trap of
the entire book urx no I'm not by
denying that you're X you've proven that
you're X classic Kafka trap and that's
the only bit of argumentation in the
book that she actually engages in so I
like this model it makes a lot of sense
to me here's the question I have so I
assume the Robyn D'Angelo is
well-intentioned
he's obviously getting quite wealthy
advancing this particular wrong set of
ideas it is possible though that you
know we have argued that people have
better access by orders of magnitude to
what takes place in their own mind than
they do to the next closest mind to them
right you can see into your own mind not
perfectly there's lots of stuff that
happens in our minds that we can't see
but but we do have some access to what
goes on inside of our own minds so Robyn
D'Angelo looking to her into her own
mind has discovered some completely
preposterous stuff and yes it offensive
if you look at it and you know it's I'm
not sure I would say it was racist
because the question is does she want to
see it that way it's clearly prejudiced
right but the point is I'm able to hide
my surprise that the black man is the
school principal I mean these are just
two but there's it's riddled throughout
the book oh right that that's hurt
speaking so she clearly has this shared
right well here's the point she has
effectively portrayed all she doesn't
know what's going on in other people's
minds yeah so having looked into her own
mind maybe she's just decided you know
her mind is a good model for everybody
else's and it isn't she's put a mirror
to herself and then declared that she
put a mirror up to society and she's
trained as a sociologist putting a
mirror to society is what sociology is
supposed to be of course sociology has
long since captured and ridiculous not
everyone there's some excellent
sociologists out there Nicolas course I
wouldn't being one he you know sociology
suggests it's more scientific than it is
I would say she is on the sociopath oh
good it was inexpensive so I just
thought I'd try it out yeah that cricket
audio I need the cricket audio yeah but
but anyway it does it does seem like she
is projecting and one would imagine that
she knows better than this but even if
she doesn't how tragic is it that we are
going to grind civilization to a halt
over a misunderstanding over whether
what goes on in Robin D'Angelo's MA
is a good match for what goes on and
everybody else is mine and so I don't
know it's it's stunning yeah I will
point out yeah friend of ours on Twitter
may have solved the problem cut the
Gordian knot as it were with respect to
white fragility so somebody had asked us
how what to do yeah in the case their
employer was insisting that they read
white for drill at a chair and Dave
suggested that the answer to this was
I'll read that if you'll read 1984 thank
you struck me as a very good answer yeah
yeah yeah all right that's good that's
good so where shall we head well let me
just share as I mentioned that I'd found
a piece of and I was looking for your
the articles of interdependence I found
a declaration of interim thank you
declaration of interdependence you know
where you can find that nowhere except
we have copies of yes sorry but it's not
online anywhere nope you can't have it
yet maybe maybe later
I probably needs it needs an update
because it's like our founding documents
right there are elements of that
document that I believe are timeless and
they're elements of that document that I
believe were very much resident in an
era where the immediate concerns of the
tarp program and too big to fail and
2008 2008 you know the financial
collapse and the you know the the
rudiments in the repeal of
glass-steagall and all of that stuff was
very much front of mind and so this is
something you always have to think about
when you're trying to build a solution
to something is how much is your focus
on the particular failures that you've
just seen I'm going to loom larger than
it should yeah the third amendment with
regard to the soldiers quarter in your
home bless the monarchy come exactly yes
right not as big an issue as they they
were concerned about and there's you
know there's also a lot of stuff in that
declaration about the very frightening
change in policing and the way it's
being wielded as a system of
extrajudicial punishment against people
who would stand up and protest
there were mass arrests of actually
peaceful protesters happening in which
people were being held for too long and
right held for too long and it dragged
into a court system that then drained
them if you're anywhere you know if
you're if you're functioning on a budget
that financial drain them financially to
put them in jeopardy with their
employers by dragging them into
situations that they you know they
couldn't get out of so there's all all
of that and there was also in the
aftermath of 9/11 you know 2008 isn't
all that far down from from 9/11 in 2001
there was all of this stuff which is
still live today where civil liberties
had been eroded in the ostensible fight
against terrorism and occupy was
portrayed as terrorist which basically
kicked in all of these special extra
constitutional provisions and allowed
the federal government to sit down with
investment banks and to conspire against
occupy with some of the most absurd
stuff like you know agents of the
federal government were actually
licensed to engage in romantic and
sexual relationships with occupy
protesters in order to infiltrate the
movement and discover what it was and
the basis that it was terrorists which
it wasn't
I mean it's preposterous so all kinds of
madness and yes
that means that back then those things
were right at the forefront of our
thinking and generating stuff like the
declaration of interdependence yeah okay
before we before we move on
this actually was my final from 20th
century debate models of human evolution
a class that you will remember as being
co-taught by pretty staunch
postmodernist actually so I just want to
raise again the point you made earlier
in passing yeah that when people tell us
you created this monster and then it
came after you and so we have no
sympathy for you
the answer is actually we have been
fighting this directly since the 90s
since we were in college since we were
in college since we were 20 20 yeah 20
years from - 20 22 at most
yeah okay so this is actually a play
in which the character is this I'm just
gonna read four lines from this play but
the characters are science human
evolution bias modern postmodern
feminism and power and I have a just an
exchange between postmodern and modern
here from 1991 this is you know my glib
college writings but postmodern
responding to someone something someone
of these characters and generalizations
all of them break down these
preconceived ideas of how we are and
what we do and start a new modern yet
modern says better yet honor and respect
that which allows you to live in the
convenience you may live in postmodern
says you're such an arrogant bastard
modern modern says to postmodern and
you're a soft and fuzzy Doughboy with
cauliflower for brains
for the English language there's there's
much more content here but you know I
just again to those who are who are
saying you you helped you're part of the
system like no we've we've been seeing
this for a long time as have many others
and part of the question is you know how
is it that many of us were being exposed
to these pretty ridiculous ideas on
college campuses I think starting you
know really in the mid 80s is when it
began to gain steam through sort of the
mid nineties and then it really kind of
died down you know we saw a little bit
of in grad school and it mostly wasn't
at the point that we were professors
starting in 2002 2001 - I wasn't there
and then it really started uptick again
in in through the 2010s and it has
struck me for a long time that this is
about those students back when we were
students who did not laugh at this and
try to understand it such that they
could fight against it with intellectual
tools actually became professors of
these fields and then they started
proliferating because the fields
themselves began to proliferate and they
have now been churning out students who
have now been moving into media and
journalism and are
and academia themselves and and so we
have a cycle that is growing in momentum
yeah I've long liked your point about
this which is that part of what we are
seeing is a generational phenomenon
right where these people who were
studying these what we've called phony
fields have now matured into a higher
level of power in the Academy and that
has resulted in other fields that have
long laughed this stuff off being unable
to resist because the the power within
the various faculties is distributed
such that they can't but I want as long
as we're here mm-hmm I want to steal man
the postmoderns right and then talk
about what what the competition really
is here okay
the postmoderns have in my opinion one
punt and it's a good one but it's one
point it's not the basis for field after
field the one point is that we are
humans and we have only our perception
as the basis for everything we think and
even to the extent that you might have
tools that would allow you to see
something what we would claim is
objectively your interaction with those
tools is still subjective right so and
this is true it is true and it results
in a lot of places where bias leaks in
to what we believe even where it is
supposed to be absolutely analytical and
rigorous and devoid of all of the things
that might bias us it can't be totally
right now here's the problem with that
so that's the steel man version
perception is between you and the world
you can't escape that and because of
that bias is impossible to stamp out
completely and I believe that that's
actually that's accurate
however if you were going to try to
stamp out bias the number one tool you
would want in your arsenal arguably the
only tool you need is science because
what science does the entire reason that
it exists the entire reason that it has
beaten every other system is that it
will tell you what's true in spite of
your bias now you have to do it right if
you have a corrupt system if you have
you know monetary corruption that is
influenced you know how quote-unquote
sian
gets done because it's only the people
who succeed at some sort of
non-scientific phenomenon like grant
writing you have repeat of a good old
boy network sort of saying with
peer-review yeah you can have all kinds
of things interfere with proper science
but if you can do the science properly
and you can be vigilant about stamping
out the things that cause science not to
be done properly then science will force
you to discover the things that you
don't intuitively believe right that's
what it does and so yes the postmoderns
are right bias is a serious problem what
do you do about it you science it to the
extent that your science is influenced
by things that it shouldn't be and is
therefore biased
what's the solution to that better
science more science its science that's
the answer to post-modernism and it
always has been so so I'm gonna I'm
gonna add I'm gonna say okay I think if
I have to pick one it's gonna be science
but I want two things I mean I want more
I want more than that but I want science
and I want art because art allows you to
view the world to other people's lenses
and you know post-modernism at least
it's modern crazy corrupt instantiations
are specifically demanding of us that we
not see the world to other people's eyes
that if we claim to be able to than we
are somehow revealing our own bigotry
but art especially narrative art you
know as especially fiction in whatever
form but to the art 3d art any of it
also just allows you to stand in someone
else's footsteps and see and science
does this in a very different way and
and if I have to pick one I pick science
but science and art together are are
going to be an incredibly potent
rejoinder to this movement and therefore
I am not too surprised to find the
shutdown stem movement and the the very
wide number of organizations that we are
hearing from and seeing in the arts that
are being gone after by this movement
it's it's they're being targeted so I
like this I still think it's the science
that narrowly corrects for the bias but
the fact is nobody reads scientist
papers I mean scientists do right in
their own field and sometimes they read
a little farther afield than that but
what moves the world is the conclusions
that you come up with the
counterintuitive things that you
discover through this process that then
get incorporated into something
beautiful and intuitive and provocative
enough to capture people's attention
which tends to be it's not even always
narrative I said I said it's easier to
point to a narrative but it's not just
out of 2d art 3d or you know I was
thinking about just staring at an
amazing sculpture even an abstract one
it's it's easier to do if it's if it's a
non abstract sculpture but yeah you
learn something about a different mind
about a different human beings mind by
by walking around some piece of art
that's been created that is the product
of another human mind and not even
necessarily mine
the mind is an interface and sometimes
the mind is the point and its content is
the point and that's what you discover
but even something like you know there
are some of these images of sculptures
that very effectively capture the finest
fabric flowing as if in the wind and
it's so compelling yeah you know or
there's a famous sculpture with
somebody's hand on somebody's leg and
the way the fingers depress the skin of
the person and the point is it's so
compelling that it actually reveals
something how could you render something
soft out of stone right so even that
counterpoint tells you something about
the way the world works or I'm
frequently stunned by what is revealed
by just simply changing one parameter of
something you can observe yourself like
stop-motion reveal certain things or you
know the the way if you look at clouds
and mountains and the way they interact
in a time-lapse and the thing is you can
read in a textbook all you want that the
atmosphere functions as a fluid right
but until you see yeah until you see
what the mountain does to the clouds as
they move around it
it's it's like what we used to say you
know enzyme is a catalyst not really
complete yes it's a catalyst in the same
way the factory is a catalyst right a
factory is a catalyst for making cars
right I mean you can so having time
lapse is obviously a fairly modern
phenomenon but I think also art has has
probably revealed what is possible and
opened up technological worlds very
often so the example that came to mind
when you were talking that I imagine
there's history written on this and I
just I don't know it but pointillism the
what is this 19th or 20th century 19th
20th century turned the century art form
in which dots are used to convey great
precision in in vast scenes seems to
presage the idea of pixels like you know
this the the idea that you can actually
reveal things through points was that in
people's heads in da Vinci's time well
you might have been she said maybe so
much was but my art history is weak but
yeah the Impressionists predate point
the formal pointillist I think so yeah
and I think what you're getting at is
the retina is actually it's the inverse
of pixels it's you know it's just as a
camera sensor would be yeah and there is
this interesting duality it's not the
duality of man but there is an
interesting duality between the
continuous and the discrete
interpretation of the world and there
are certain things that are simply
discrete and there are other things that
are continuous and then there are many
things which do not fall wholly in one
or the other category and therefore one
needs to spend time borrowing from the
alternative in order to see what it is
that you were missing what's in your
blind spot because you had looked at it
as discrete when in fact it was
continuous at some level so and this is
you know this is science fiction
services purpose as well like scientific
investigations have gotten ideas from
things that had written in science
fiction in part because what it what
science fiction reveals what art may
reveal in other forums is maybe the
categories we are currently using art
right or maybe the boundaries
aren't quite where we thought they were
or maybe the boundaries were where we
thought they were but those boundaries
are moving because other things are
changing and art can allow you to live
in that alternative space for a little
bit and consider it and sometimes like
nope actually not right interesting to
spend some time there but that's not
right and sometimes it can cause people
to go ah actually I think I think we do
need an update or radical change but you
don't need to we need to actually build
a whole new foundation over here with a
new kind of science because the
categories we were using you know of boy
I'm also not up-to-date on the various
older versions of what the world is made
of but you know it turns out that fire
earth water and air are not the the
basal elements of life right right so
it's sort of hints at the periodic table
but it didn't get there it's got the
wrong thing you don't get there and you
couldn't you could not just do a brick
in the wall model from fire earth water
and air to get to the periodic table you
actually need to go all the way back in
the decision tree to the question what
are what is it made of what are the
fundamentals and rebuild from there yeah
yeah so it's just a very that's a very
good way of putting it
so I guess so where oh I don't know
exact thing we started work yeah 50 55
minutes 50 or 55 minutes all right so we
have a few minutes left I guess um did
you have something in mind with yeah
let's let's spend a couple minutes here
so I was listening to your conversation
with Eric in the podcast that you did
with him a couple weeks ago to a CO and
you mentioned flatland and I thought I
imagine that most of our listeners
viewers know this book but it prompted
me to think this and I know you want to
add something to this so this is this is
this book I think you can see it
flatland by Edwin Abbott it was written
in 1884 Victorian era England and I read
it when I was 12 11 or 12 something like
that and I had two very distinct
reactions to it one of my reactions was
in line with why I think you invoked it
in that conversation with Eric which was
it provides
it does exactly we were just talking
about in fact it provides a lens into
imagining what it might be like to live
in a universe in which there are things
bigger than the universe that you live
in and therefore so outside your sphere
of experience that you can't really
interpret them so when a sphere walks
through the flat the 2-dimensional
flatland universe of abbott and i
haven't reread it in decades so in line
I may be butchering it a little bit but
when a sphere comes through the plane
that is flatland it looks like first a
point and then a line and then I I'm I
guess it be a point and then a circle
that gets bigger and then a circle and
then a point and then it disappears
again but it can never reveal itself as
a sphere because spheres don't exist in
a two-dimensional landscape and that
that alone that understanding what won't
be understandable what won't be
comprehensible even if you can get
glimmers of it in your current world is
amazing and I think it along with so
many other experiences in my life helped
me think about you know how so how do we
know you know how what are the questions
we could ask and how would we end up
answering those questions
so it was greatly foundational for me
when I read it and then it's also true
that this book is deeply sexist now it
is I just I went to Wikipedia just
before this to see um Justin let's not
deeply sexist it's objectively sex it's
objectively sexist but no mathematically
substitute here's the thing wikipedia
says it's satire in the circle right so
let's just put that aside because I
think this is a revisionist history but
you know who knows like mate maybe but
the fact is that in the two-dimensional
landscape where males are triangles or
squares and they aspire to be circles
with sort of an infinite number of sides
they're there for 2d they're polygons
females are one-dimensional they're
lines and then the one-dimensional
landscape were where men are lines women
are dots and in the three-dimensional
landscape where where men are cubes or
spheres women are polygons it's insane
it's deeply insulting and I read it and
let be kidding me and then I thought a
little bit about the scant that I knew
about the era in which he'd been writing
which
that point was 100 years prior and I
thought okay well you know what I can
still I can still get out of this book
the remarkable truth in it while also
being perturbed by this insanity in it
and that doesn't actually alter the the
value that I have in it
so that was 1884 there's also so this is
a copy of a book that my mother gave to
our son Zach a number of years ago it's
it's highland robert heinlein stranger
in a strange land and starship troopers
great books both of them written let's
see stranger in a strange land was
written in 1961 Heinlein also has a
tremendous amount to teach us and he's
also of his era and it's kind of
misogynist and I actually remember
having a conversation with one of our
male students on our ecuador study
abroad trip in 2016 2016 we were bunch
of us were sitting around talking about
science fiction and I mentioned stranger
in a strange land he said to me how can
you like that book it's yeah the
treatment of women I said yeah sure when
a woman isn't isn't great in that book
and I don't like that part of that book
but that doesn't mean that there's not
things that you can learn from it so the
idea of canceling entire you know
historical figures or works of art or
scientific ideas because the people who
engage in them were of their time and
flawed is obviously a road that we
should not want to go down and you have
a better example yet well there there's
so many example I but before we get
there I do want to say I hope somebody
will take up flatland and bring it into
modernity where it turns out maybe I
mean you can imagine females being
prisms that only intersect the plane in
which flatland takes place at a line
this is about male perception that
females are yeah I think nicely
introduced grok there from Heinlein
himself well there you go
there you go although I still can't
quite spell it Grunk yeah do you're okay
- you're okay I would tend to say CK and
then I get corrected this is all I know
[Laughter]
yeah well I would just say look you know
the problem is and you know I don't even
know how to do this with the Internet
I know how to do this in a conversation
you might beings but I don't know how to
do it with with the internet because you
have to fear the editor right what the
editor is going to do with what you say
is potentially going to overwhelm any
point that you can make and that's a
tragic lesson when I learned in college
the first time and keeps getting
reinforced but obviously you need Mark
Twain
for example in order to understand race
in America because he gives us a
snapshot and he gives us a very humane
snapshot but it is not a snapshot devoid
of what we now call the n-word and if
you want to cancel that book because it
contains a word that you've now been
told that any white person who utters it
is guilty of a crime well now you've
just robbed us of one of the greatest
tools we have likewise and you know
maybe my favorite song ever is hurricane
by Bob Dylan from 1976 1976 it is for
those of you who don't know and I really
would invite you to go find it and
listen to it carefully right it is a
story of hurricane Carter Rubin Carter
who was falsely convicted of murder in a
deeply racially biased court system
right so the police and the courts
conspired against him and convicted him
of a murder that he had not committed
and the song is blistering right it is
an absolutely blistering attack on the
system that did this and it is also it
is not an over an overly analytical song
it is a song that in Deitz
the humanity of the people involved in
this crime and humanizes rubin carter
who we have been led to believe we in
civilization have been led to believe is
a bad guy who did something bad and
that's why he's been locked up so anyway
that song contains I hate that I have to
say the N word here right but I don't
know how else to do it so I don't get
edited to that one sentence and it'll be
about one word you know I'll find video
of me uttering that one word
out of context and suddenly the ability
to say here's what I was saying I was
quoting Bob Dylan I was quoting Bob
Dylan and a song in which he is
revealing what again I don't think this
is the right word but he was revealing
what we now would be told is white
supremacy right a system that is
systematically indifferent to the
interests of black people right he goes
through it he explains he actually
details not only the circumstances of
the the crime and the investigation but
the bad witnesses and their perverse
incentives and the structure of the
court that Carter finds himself facing
the whole and the press I mean he goes
through the whole thing it's just it's a
tour de force and the point is you you
want to rob us of that you want to rub
your kids of that you want to explain
white supremacy and not have that as one
of the tools in your toolkit right what
a song actually instrumental in getting
hurricane Carter release absolutely yeah
so the point is like this is how it's
done people right it's done narrative
Lee and it's done unflinchingly and it
is not a stanza and just not I mean I
understand why you try to say the words
I it is really against my religion okay
to do it and say n-word because for one
thing it interrupts a rhyme that's
important to the whole thing what the
rhyme is obvious though yeah well okay
so the stanza I know it by heart but can
I do it in front of a family um let's
see it was Oh to the white folks who
watched he was a revolutionary bum and
to the black folks he was just a crazy
[ __ ] nobody doubted that he pulled the
trigger and though they could not
produce the gun the DA said he was the
one who did the deed and the all-white
jury agreed I mean that's beautiful
poetry yeah right and it is a very ugly
word and it has to be there in order for
that piece of poetry to work yeah I
think you probably couldn't have called
it up after after saying the word if you
would replace it with n-word there right
you what you would have lost your place
I would have lost my place and I would
have been heartbroken that this
important tool had been made though I
mean yeah what do you do so look I mean
just like it's obvious it's obvious that
this is not a word that you are trying
to use it's no need of that word to use
in earnest but some
times there's a need to discuss its use
in Twain or to discuss its use by Dylan
or to discuss its modern use you don't
you need discretion and you know half
the only way a system can work is if you
have discretion to decide where a use is
legitimate and where a uses illegitimate
and you know what you're probably even
going to have to be generous because
even if you say well Twain is a
legitimate case Dylan is a legitimate
case most cases are illegitimate and
that's true
there gonna be some gray area case yes
right and I mean in fact who was that
this woman who just got canceled for
wearing blackface while mocking who was
it the the juror the talking head on TV
is it megyn kelly is it megyn kelly yes
we should [ __ ] her when in fact what
she had done was say something super
clumsy but you know she she had said
something super clumsy about black faces
she's trying to navigate something and
that's my recollection anyway and then
somebody makes a Halloween costume
mocking her for her tone-deafness on
this issue and you're gonna ruin her
life over this I mean even if it's an
error it's not a an error of some you
know profound rot at her core it's an
error we've talked about the death of
empathy it's also the death of satire
yeah yeah
right again the tool you would want most
prominently at this moment in order to
sort out this really difficult stuff
you're gonna rob us of satire that must
be because you have an objective that
involves power and if we can satirize
stuff if we can laugh at ourselves then
you won't get there so you know alright
well I think we are at a little over an
hour and I don't know how how we do this
part here I have some announcements do
you have any more announcements before
we sign off come find us at unity 2020
you come to articles of unity org the
hashtag unity 2020 will also lead you to
our twitter handle at articles of unity
and do you have the final card to put up
I announced some things are you if I can
figure it out okay while you're talking
I will say the standard now standard
things that we say at the end that we
will do start another livestream in
about 15 minutes
well we will be taking your super chat
questions starting with the top monetary
value ones from this live stream and
then moving about halfway through to the
questions that come in in the order that
they come in in the next live stream
that that link I think is already live
or it is start it is set to be live soon
I don't know we'll figure you now
discover yeah the state of that link and
get it to you in the description of this
video very very shortly after we go off
here so we have a Clips channel now
which I've got a got a very good guy
who's making clips from these episodes
as they come out and he's working
backwards a little bit as well Dark
Horse clips I think is what it's called
and personally I don't have it exactly
written down Dark Horse clips please go
subscribe if you are we've been hearing
from a lot of people they're looking for
bits from from these episodes so they
don't have to necessarily ask people to
share an entire hour right half we have
the dark west membership at my patreon
which gives you access to a private Q&A
every month with the two of us and I'm
thinking about that go check out the
last one which you can access right well
you have you know you have to be a
member to access it it's private to
access the prior one yeah okay yeah but
you know there they're not there they're
like our Q&A is that we do here except
it's a smaller group and so those who
were involved live last time we're able
to chat in a more constrained and they
were able to basically work the
conversation more effectively than I
think can happen in a live chat that
happens here so they're live and then we
leave them up and then also we've
there's now a discord server that we are
making available to patrons of either of
ours at the $5 and level anything else
nope I think that about that said about
15 minutes in about 15 minutes thanks
for joining us see you soon
see you soon yeah we're still here yeah
we need a there it is
you